hey youtubers is Charlie happy Friday so
a lot of you guys have been requesting a
new Star Wars video explaining what's
going to be canon with the new Star Wars
movies so I'm gonna explain the books
the movies the videogames everything
that they're including is part of this
new storyline that they're doing the
good thing is that they're not throwing
the entire expanded universe away the
Clone Wars TV show is like the biggest
thing that they're keeping so if you're
a big fan of the Clone Wars you don't
have to worry they're not dumping that
in the trash
we even have ahsoka on Star Wars rebels
if you haven't seen the first episode of
Star Wars rebels season two they've
actually aired it a couple times since
Star Wars Celebration earlier this year
it bridges the gap with Clone Wars in a
really interesting way and they just
announced that the clone troopers some
of the clone troopers are coming back
but that's just part of it for the
longest time the Star Wars Expanded
Universe just existed in the books and
the games that was actually where I
picked it up with the Thrawn Trilogy
unfortunately that's one of the things
that's getting thrown in the dumpster so
like Grand Admiral Thrawn not gonna be a
thing in the new Star Wars universe that
that's okay though I mean if you really
like that stuff just go back and read it
again but there's this big Lucasfilm
initiative that they're calling journey
to Star Wars The Force awakens and it's
a way to describe all of the new books
that they're publishing as part of the
new Canon the book they just released
Star Wars aftermath is part of that
that's kind of the beginning of that but
they did release a Tarkin novel that's
also a part of that there's also a bunch
of smaller books that they're writing
for young children which I totally will
not judge you if you want to read
starting with the first book Star Wars
aftermath if you haven't read this yet
this is all about what happens to the
Empire in the wake of the Battle of
Endor so like they're basically
shattered they have to regroup and
figure out what they're gonna do next so
it's all about the rise of the new order
which is like the name of the new
organization built on the bones of the
Empire it also starts to create some
context for what's going on with force
users you know both dark and light side
now we know kylo Ren was part of the
Knights of Ren that's how he chose his
name he has like a real name that we
don't know yet so there's a lot of
theories about what that might be I
don't want to do any spoilery stuff but
there is one really big theory about who
he's related to and why he's so obsessed
with Darth Vader after math just shows
you kylo Ren going around searching for
Sith artifact so he's searching for
former possessions of Darth Vader's like
his lightsaber
remember Darth Vader technically had two
lightsabers there was the lightsaber he
created when he was Anakin Skywalker
that actually shows up in the episode 7
trailer and then there was the later
lightsaber
that he built when he became Darth Vader
the most important lightsaber to keep
track of is Anakin's we meet a really
cool bounty hunter droid named mr. bones
bounty hunter droids gonna continue to
be a thing in the Star Wars universe we
learn a little bit more about the
hierarchy of the Empire in the wake of
the Battle of Endor even though the
emperor was supreme ruler had a grand
design for the galaxy there were a
circle of advisors around him so they
all begin to rise to power they have
their own ideas about the direction they
should be taking in the dark side of the
force is really important for that and
we kind of learned what's going on with
some of the original cast like Han and
Chewie
so Star Wars aftermath getting
relatively mixed reviews on the way it
ended its storyline again it is the
beginning of this journey to Star Wars
The Force awakens book series so read it
don't read it you don't really have to
understand what's going on to the books
to understand what's going on in the
movie but it does paint a bigger picture
like it does add context the next book
after that is called lost stars which is
about like a wedge antilles type
character that goes to the Imperial
Academy but then decides to join the
rebellion then there's a Princess Leia
book then there's a han Solo Chewie
adventure then there's a Luke Skywalker
book so like those last three books the
ones about the original characters
probably gonna be the most popular ones
so you can wait for those you'll
probably find on top of all that stuff
if you guys didn't know Marvel comics
that started republishing Star Wars
comics like they have a new Star Wars
comic there's a new Princess Leia comic
they even have a Lando comic they just
started everything that happens in those
comics is gonna influence what's
happening in the new movies you may have
heard about a big change they made to
the Princess Leia Han Solo storyline
they like they introduced this big twist
in Han Solo's backstory a bunch of
people got really upset about it I think
it's fine I mean they're trying to take
the character in a new direction without
changing him too much but if you want to
learn all about that just read the
Marvel Star Wars comic book let's just
say we're learning new things about Han
Solo's backstory that are going to
inform the future of his relationship
with Princess Leia and then of course in
the video game universe Star Wars
Battlefront gonna be can into the movies
too they're also they're gonna have like
this event in it called the battle of
jakku jakku is this planet in the Star
Wars Episode 7 trailer so it's gonna
explain why this Star Destroyer crashed
on jakku like why this wreckage is
sitting here so as long as you're
watching the Clone Wars reading the new
comics reading the new books that
they've been publishing in the last year
so you'll totally be fine all those
things all Canon the things that I
really want to learn more about though
are the Knights of Ren like this weird
organization that kylo Ren belonged to
it's not Sith but they're not good Jedi
so it's kind of weird the only thing
that I know JJ Abrams has like
completely deleted from Star Wars is the
idea of midi-chlorians he said there is
no mention of midi-chlorians in the new
movies which I think everybody's gonna
be really happy about but I think what
they're trying to do with some of the
new darkside characters is slowly move
away from the Sith is this crutch for
bad guys think about the way you
interpret religion there's a lot of
different faiths there's like you know
there's Muslims there's Christianity
there's Hinduism all kinds of different
religions around the world the new films
are just gonna explore some alternate
interpretations of the force so like
Supreme Leader Snoke the character the
Andy Serkis is playing supposed to be
force sensitive very evil character but
not a sith character I know a lot of you
been asking me about Darth Plagueis JJ
Abrams already said that he's not in the
new movies the reason everyone was
wondering about him is because he
arguably found a way to cheat death and
supposedly Andy Serkis his character is
like this ancient creature so everyone's
like well is this the character that
Palpatine was talking about when he was
talking about Darth Plagueis I don't
think that's the case I think that Andy
Serkis his character is a new character
I've seen a couple crazy theories about
Darth Vader being in the new trilogy the
the reason that people thought that
Darth Vader might be in the new trilogy
is because last week as part of like the
Star Wars aftermath storyline there's
this graffiti that said Vader lives and
it's all about kylo Ren so people are
like maybe kylo Ren is trying to
resurrect Darth Vader but I think that
he is just trying to become the new
Darth Vader in a metaphorical way like
he's trying to take that persona so when
people say that Darth Vader is present
in the new films I think that he's just
going to try and manifest him through
his personality his mask was inspired by
Vader's he's searching for Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber so I think that
he's just obsessed with Darth Vader I
don't think he's physically trying to
resurrect him but that's just my
interpretation that's just what I
thought after I read that rumor more on
the Star Wars Expanded Universe though
let me know when did you guys first get
into the expanding universe was it in
the 90s with the original books like
when the book started being published or
was it later with the Clone Wars when
that started it is kind of a bummer
they're dropping some of the cooler
stuff from the Star Wars Expanded
Universe but
but I think I'll end up happening is is
they'll republish a lot of those stories
under a different banner and the price
start bundling it so you'll be able to
get it free even cheaper like whenever
Dark Horse passed the comics to Marvel
they actually they sold like this giant
bundle of every Dark Horse Star Wars
comic ever made for 300 dollars which I
think was even more than like 50% off so
it's like you could have gotten all
those comics for like super super cheap
but because we're getting a little bit
closer I'm gonna try and start doing
more regular Star Wars videos so be sure
to subscribe to get everything I don't
know if I'm gonna have time to do Star
Wars rebels videos I'll at least do a
video for the first couple of episodes
it's gonna start airing on television
later in October on Disney XD just like
it did last year in case you guys
haven't seen it I actually did do a
video for the first episode of rebels
season 2 you can click here to watch
that some awesome people show up in that
and you can click here for all my other
Star Wars Episode 7 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five and I'll see you guys tonight